الهزيمه المفاجئه امام ناميبيا بهدف دون
مقابل في الجوله الاولى من الكاس
الافريقيه عقدت وضعيه المنتخب التونسي
الذي يدخل مباراه الليله امام مالي متصدره
المجموعه بخيار الفوز فقط من اجل انعاش
اماله في التاهل للدور الثاني قبل ملاقاه
جنوب افريقيا في الجوله الاخيره ومصالحه
الجماهير التونسيه ومن المتوقع ان تشهد
التشكيله الاساسيه للمدرب جلال القادري
تغييرات في كل الخطوط ويبقى الشك حول
اللاعب الذي سيشارك بين حمزه رفيعه وسيف
الدين
الجزيري اليوم اذا نحبوا نواصل في
المغامره اعنا ونمشي لابعد ما يمكن نحقق
اهدافنا لازمنا نعمل رده فعل رده فعل
ايجابيه ثم مسؤوليه كبيره من الاطراف الكل
من المجموعه خليني نحكي على الاقل على
الاطار الفني اللاعبين المسؤولين متواجدين
كل الاطراف نشعر بالخيبه ماما جماهير
التونسيه
كل قمنا بمباراه اولى ما كانتش في المستوى
والا ما كانتش في النيفو اللي احنا نحب
عليه ما حققنا
النتيجه اللي جينا
عليها فو دو باركور ان شاء الله نعرفوا
كفاش ندركها في بقيه المشوار من جهته يامل
المنتخب المالي بقياده المدرب ايريك تشال
مواصله انطلاقته القويه التي بداها في
الجوله الاولى بالفوز على جنوب افريقيا
بهدفين دون مقابل وقد حذر المدرب لاعبيه
من التراخي امام نصور قرطاج وطلبهم
بالتركيز للحصول على النقاط
الثلاث نتوقع مواجهه منتخب رفيع المستوى
يمتلك سجلا مميزا وعندما يقدمون كره القدم
الخاصه بهم فانهم يشكلون خطوره كبيره
خصوصا وقت الازمات لذلك نتوقع مباراه صعبه
مع فريق جيد
ويتصدر المنتخب المالي المجموعه بثلاث
نقاط وبفارق الاهداف عن ناميبيا بينما
يحتل المنتخب التونسي المركز الثالث
متقدما على جنوب افريقيا رابع الترتيب
بفارق
الاهداف
ان